[Music]
can ai do math and i don't mean two plus
two i mean pure mathematics the paper
we're going to look at today is called
formal mathematics statement curriculum
learning and presents an automated
system to prove mathematical theorems in
a symbolic fashion what's even more
crazy is that this system was able to
solve two problems of the international
mathematical olympiad which is a contest
that real gifted high school students
get to take part in this system is way
beyond previous systems that have
attempted anything like this because
formal mathematics and automated
mathematics that uses algorithms to
prove things lags a lot behind the
informal mathematics that you might know
a lot of previous techniques relied on
proof searching essentially brute
forcing their way to a proof guided by
some heuristics and this paper improves
on that drastically it uses language
models to guide the proof search and it
uses a technique called expert iteration
to build itself automatically a
curriculum of harder and harder
statements to prove now the implications
of this are cool for math but it goes
way beyond math this is essentially
symbolic reasoning it's the model
teaching itself to learn more and more
and that's exciting for many fields of
ai so here's how it goes this video
right here is a paper review a
comprehensive review of me going through
the paper explaining to you what is in
the paper what its main contributions
are what i think are the weaknesses and
strengths of the paper and much more
after this video you should have a good
understanding of what is in the paper
otherwise i haven't done my job in the
next video released tomorrow i'll be
interviewing the first author of this
paper which is a huge privilege because
if you watch this video you'll see that
i have many open questions i'm a noob at
formal mathematics and i suppose many
people are and therefore even though the
paper is written really well i had a lot
of questions i even had some criticisms
and all of that was answered when i
spoke to the author so if you watch
tomorrow's video you'll get an insight
into the behind the scenes of this
research how it came about what worked
what didn't how problems were solved
during the research process and much
more the author i'm interviewing has
actually seen my paper review and is
directly able to answer to any questions
that i raised there please let me know
how you like these formats in the
comments if you do like the video please
leave a like tell someone to subscribe
and i'll see you around bye
hello there today we're looking at
formal mathematics statement curriculum
learning by researchers of openai epfl
in cambridge this paper presents or
applies the technique of expert
iteration to the domain of proving
formal mathematics statements
this is not enough yet they also bring
language modeling into the picture so
you have a proof searcher in this paper
or a proof search procedure that is
guided by language models
to focus to search for mathematics
proofs and then the expert iteration
procedure makes the system better and
better and better by always
incorporating new statements that it has
been able to prove into its training set
and so the domain or the difficulty of
statements that it is able to prove
expands iteration by iteration the
combination of this is that they're able
to solve two problems i believe of the
imo of the international mathematics
olympiad which is a difficult math
challenge for high school students and
this has this has implications beyond
just math so this can be applied
anywhere where agents need to
reason over some sort of symbolic
structure um and you know this is
wide-ranging this could be agents acting
in the real world uh this could be
reinforcement learning things this could
be i don't know
assistance for clinical trials and
whatnot essentially anywhere where such
a
a more formal system more logical type
of reasoning is required so we're going
to look into this paper and and what
they do this builds on a bit of other
work
but i think it can be looked in it can
be looked at in isolation
so they claim right here in the
introduction that deep learning has been
very good at sort of
many tasks like you know language
modeling there's vision image generation
however they say it has not yet enjoyed
a comparable success in tasks that
require extensive planning and symbolic
reasoning and
the domain of mathematics proves is a
good domain because it has these
challenges but also
you don't exactly rely on external data
that much like you can you can prove
things in mathematics kind of by
yourself in the basement or in this case
you can verify a proof pretty quickly so
the challenges in this domain are it has
an extremely large search space and an
infinite action space when you prove a
statement in mathematics
there are many things you could
potentially do like infinitely many
things
it's not only about manipulating the
symbols that are there often you need to
introduce new symbols they they for
example they say
you could generate a witness like there
exists an x that fulfills some things
where x was never a symbol before so you
have like infinite things at your
disposal now the question is how do you
prove a statement
maybe we'll just direct a little bit go
into how these mathematics proving
things work if you really do them
formally so in their types of system
they have some kind of statement to be
proven so i'm going to call that
statement s that is a formal statement
that just is essentially is the
formalization the exact uh writing down
of something like a theorem as you would
find it in a textbook but instead of
using words and language it uses like
a defined syntax in in a predefined
system
so how to prove this system in order to
prove the system what you need to do is
you need to build up a tree so you need
to decompose this system in some way
into multiple sub statements
um and the way you do this is as you
would do as a human you you know you'd
have some sort of a proof and then you
say okay in order to prove that i need
the following three things to be true
right so these would be the three things
like this is a sub statement one the sub
statement two a sub statement three and
generally the derivation from
such like from this to this i believe
that's called a tactic so you can apply
tactics to sort of reformulate things uh
into
its sub into it into its um sub things
in
i'm speaking very informally right here
because as you might guess i'm also a
noob in this domain and i hope the the
interview uh will tell us a little bit
more about how these things work but as
far as i understand you want to
decompose these things into sub
statements and then these sub statements
again you can decompose into stuff and
this is a context free grammar right so
this is a sub statement like this
should be provable by itself
independently of the other
sub-statements and you build this tree
for as long as you want until the leaves
right here are either the sort of the
preconditions for the theorem so a
theorem could be you know uh for any two
rational numbers so if the leaf right
here says you know this is a rational
number then
we're done because that's a precondition
for the theorem also if it's like some
sort of a lemma that i already know or
if it's like a a fundamental um how do
you how do you call them an axiom if
it's a fundamental axiom i also stop so
i'm gonna build up this proof tree until
every single leaf is either something
that i already know or something that i
can assume to be true and then i have
proven the i've proven the original
statement because the tree represents
the proof now how to build the tree that
is the question right i could i could
derive many different sub loops i could
derive many different sub statements
from the from the top statement the fact
that i derived these particular ones
that then lead me to approve that is the
magic of proving things in mathematics
right that's what mathematicians do for
a job and
you can already see that this is not an
easy and easy thing you might think of
something like alpha alpha zero alphago
and that is a good guess but whereas
alphago has defined actions so all of
these things that alphago could do
are pretty defined like how it could
expand the tree
not in the case of mathematical proofs
there are there's a complex and infinite
set of tactics potentially involving
exogenous mathematical terms that have
to be generated
so
quite a challenging domain
the other one so there is the infinite
action space which is one of the
tragedies problems and the other problem
is this no direct self-play
setup so whereas in something like alpha
0 i can train with self play
in mathematics proving there is no
adversary i cannot
have a two player game and the two
players get better and better and better
it's a statement you can either prove it
or not like that it has the difficulty
that it has there is no there's no
opponent that can be hard or easy
however
um so they say this the this it prevents
the naive application of the symmetric
self-play
objective
however
they say that they observe that the key
role of self-play is to provide an
unsupervised curriculum
and i'm not exactly sure honestly how
they arrive at that statement if that is
just sort of their their hypothesis
right here and the sort of the paper
validates it um i don't see any
exogenous reason why that might be true
but it is a reasonable statement to make
right uh the self play self play is
really good because every both opponents
start very weak and then they all get
sort of better in steps
and
that is essentially a curriculum
so the
question is how can we come up with an
automated way to generate a curriculum
for proving formal math statements
that is going to be
one of the challenges the other
challenge the challenge of infinite
action space they say that this has been
addressed in past work
um
by sampling from a language model we're
going to look a little bit into how this
is done but this is by the same authors
so they have previously dealt with
this by having the proof search like the
the thing that decides what node to
expand in the proof tree
be guided by a language model that has
been trained on a number of proofs and
that sort of
takes a good guess at what to do next uh
so it kind of guides the the search much
like the the value and policy networks
in like alpha zero guide the tree search
because that is also inherently too
large
so they say
um
they empirically show that
when the difficulty of the auxiliary
problems is varied oh sorry we skipped
apart
so they they say we propose to supply
auxiliary set of problem statements
without requiring proofs of varying
difficulty we show that when the
difficulty of these auxiliary statements
is varied enough a simple expedition
procedure is able to solve a curriculum
of increasingly difficult problems
and
so
what they're saying is they're going to
provide so here here is maybe you know
statement one statement two statement
three that i want to prove ultimately
and these are really difficult so what
i'm going to do is i'm just going to
put like statement 4 statement five
um i'm going to put these statements in
here i don't know what's wrong with the
with the pen
sorry
i'm just going to put these statements
um
in in there and as long as they vary in
difficulty so there is like a difficulty
gradient and i just fill sort of the
space
with um statement six statement seven
with with various difficulty statements
what i can do is i can do an expert
iteration procedure so what does the
expert duration procedure do essentially
it just says that i start with some sort
of a model that can solve
you know some kind of a difficulty of
statements let's say s6 and s7 are the
easiest ones
then i take the results of that system
and the proofs it generated to retrain
the same system and that would result in
a better system and the better system i
would be able to solve slightly more
hard statements
and you know since i now solve these
slightly more hard statements i can feed
the proofs that i found back into the
system right train them on those proofs
because i now know the proofs because i
found them and that system will get even
better
so the expert iteration procedure is the
act of
always going to your best system
gathering the data that it has figured
out through you know guiding the search
um
then
taking that data and enter and
retraining the system on this new data
to make it even stronger
right this this is based on two facts
you can't just do that with any system
right this is based on the fact that
here a machine learn system interacts
with a search system and uh the
interaction is what
makes the difference so the combination
of the two is better than just the
search system and better
especially than just the machine
learning system
so
you can
if the machine learning system itself
has a certain performance adding the
search on top will increase that
performance and therefore allow you to
get to more and better training data
that you couldn't have just gotten with
the ml system itself if you just have
the ml system you just
stop be stuck forever in a loop of
always having the same difficulty
because all you do is feed the output of
the ml system back into the ml system
but if you add a component on top that
makes it stronger that gives you better
data that can make the ml system itself
stronger then you add the search again
that will make it even stronger in
combination
so that is um that is the story of
expert iteration and of this paper right
here they go a little bit into the
environment they have this lean
environment which i have no clue about
but this is like a formal environment
for mathematics proofs one of one of
many i'm i'm being informed um there
there's also one that's called metamath
and
uh apparently lean
lean benefits from higher level tactics
uh which were shown to be beneficial in
in this context
but essentially for our purposes it is
oh and also the proofs lean proofs are
typically 10 times shorter than other
systems but you know for our purposes
just assume that we have some kind of a
system where we can build proofs like
this this tree right here from
from statements
um
so they next go into into experts so
they have a bit of data sets um that's
what they describe here they we're going
to expert iteration uh expert iteration
consists in iteratively training models
on their previously sampled trajectories
that's
essentially expert iteration
as for a model they use decoder only
transformers so they use language models
uh which just shows you sort of the
versatility of language models
the biggest model i think that they use
uses 36 layers and 700 million trainable
parameters so this is not too big of a
model right this is
a reasonably sized it's it's big but
it's not like
uh gpt three big
they pre-trained this which i found
interesting on a combination of
mathematics data sets but also common
crawl which is a language just it's a
web scrape right um
that is is very interesting that the
pre-training happens
on natural language and not just on
mathematics data maybe you need this
this many uh
this many
tokens to pre-train the model because
the model itself is kind of big
um but i i'd wonder you know what kind
of difference that makes
and what is what the transfer
is from the natural language to the
mathematics because math is is very
cryptic um not even sure if they have
let me find
a proof
here maybe they've listed
so yeah you can you can see
these are sort of the things you would
find in this is a
a terminal an internal trace of this
lean environment or there their their uh
their gym environment around the lean
environments so you'd have like these
tactics states you can see right here uh
these these are have nothing to do with
natural language right
um then you have the tactics that you
run you apply
this uh
nat prime dvd mall hp dot mp tactic
i have no idea what it is and that
transforms the above tactic state i
believe into the bottom tactic state
i'm not going to parse this because i
again i have no clue
what it means but
you can see that these statements
they're they're very formal
and they have nothing to do with natural
language
still obviously humans made them as a
series of characters and therefore there
might also always be some transfer
so how do they train this
how do they train this thing um
so the the transformer is trained
to suggest kind of what to do next in
such a proof
and
that is called a proof step
so the proof step objective that they
train the transformer with
consists in generating a proof step give
which is a tactic
given a goal which is a tactic state so
you're trying to get somewhere which is
the the root of the current tree or
subtree you're considering and you're
generating a tactic which means like how
to expand the tree um
given that that you know you are at this
particular route
and they also
condition this objective on the current
declaration which is the theorem name
which remains the same throughout the
proof search
they make some they give some
explanation why they do this but
essentially the
what they train the transformer with
looks like this there is a keyword decal
then there's the declaration which is
the name of the
theorem then there is a goal and then
here you put the
goal state the tactic state
that you want to achieve
and then the keyword proof step and then
here is where the proof step goes so
during inference obviously you you leave
this away and you let the language model
generate this part but during training
you put right here
any any proof um from any proof that you
know was successful you'd put the
corresponding proof step there
so this is
a
yeah this is a language modeling
objective
uh you just train on all of the proofs
that you know that are true uh you put
them into this particular form you put
all of their individual three expansion
steps into this particular
form and you train a language model on
it and that apparently works pretty well
this is already from their from their
previous work that this works pretty
well
they also have they explained this here
the rationale for conditioning on the
declaration name is to hint our models
on the position of the current
declaration in the math lib library it
can be considered a weak proxy signal
for the large amount of information not
shown to the model
so there is a full
there is available imports
uh currently open declarations module
names notations declared instances so
and that that is where i really am a
noob there is this math lib library
which is a library inside of this lean
environment and i'm going to guess the
analogy would be like it has a bunch of
functions you can call it has a bunch of
stuff there that you could potentially
use
and obviously this is not going to all
fit into the little context that we have
right here that we're going to feed into
the transformer
so what you're going to do is you simply
give this declaration name and if the
model has seen enough of those things
it
it obviously some of these function
calls will be in this proof step step
right here if you start out with proofs
that already exist so some of these
function calls will be in there and the
declaration hints sort of where in the
library you are which means that which
functions you can currently call which
variables exist and so on i'm exactly
sure but um
essentially
i would i would read the declaration if
i were a programmer i would read the the
declaration as maybe the
the project and the file i'm currently
in and what imports there are
i would read the goal as the
function
definition or sorry the function header
and the docs string that tells me what
should happen in this function and then
the proof step i would consider the
function itself the implementation that
is a very bad analogy but
approximately like this it's a weird mix
between programming and and mathematics
this formal mathematics proves
so they train the language model on this
so now the language model can suggest
new proof steps you give it the
declaration and the goal it can suggest
new proof steps right that is
one thing they train the language model
with they in at the same time train it
also with this proof size objective so
they give an other they give other
inputs to the language model that they
train it on again we have the
declaration name we have the goal but
then we have a different keyword instead
of proof step now we have the keyword
proof size and then here is a proof size
bucket token and that's simply a letter
from a to k
and that letter encodes
one of 11 buckets
and the buckets represent the size of
the proofs again during training we know
the proof size right or the size of the
proof step or
maybe the size of the whole proof i'm
not entirely sure
i think it's the size of the whole proof
um
yeah represents a proof size estimate
bucket for the current goal okay so for
the for the proof of the current goal
how long is it
and during training we know it so we
just put it here during inference time
again this is the thing that we are
going to let the model predict so the
model should guess how long a proof is
going to be without necessarily
producing it that's what this keyword up
here does so the bottom one simply says
how long is it maybe you know probably
going to be
and this it's pretty neat how they do it
so they have these 11 buckets
infinite proof sizes go to bucket 0 and
then bucket 1 gets the longest proofs
bucket 2 gets slightly smaller proofs
and the shortest proof scale into bucket
10. why do they encode it like this
now it comes to the place where
how or what do you search so you're now
in the proof search right you're in
inference mode you ask your model for to
suggest a bunch of these proof steps to
you that we saw
right here so you ask your model please
suggest a bunch of those proof steps you
sample from the model a bunch of times
and now how what where should you which
one should you do of course you could go
by i guess the log
like the likelihood of these proof steps
but as far as i can understand
they
weigh
they weigh
the tactics that they want to use
so they
they value different goals
ah this is about which goal do i want to
pursue next okay
so they've they they ask themselves
which goal should i produce or should i
pursue next in my proof search
to value goals as we run proof searches
we sample the proof size bucket token
and record the logits for each viable
bucket and use them to get a weighted
average with the following formula so
the formula itself is not really
important but what is important they use
the buck like the prediction of how long
a proof is going to be to guide their
selection of goals which means that
the exact way they do it is
they say
if a model assigns p0 equals 1 which
means that the model puts all the weight
on bucket zero which if you remember as
the infinite proofs so if the model
predicts this proof size is going to be
infinite which means that it's not going
to work right the proof size infinite
means that it hasn't been at least it
hasn't been proven yet right the proof
search in or the data set hasn't been
able to prove this particular statement
so the size is is infinite
then the value
as you can see is zero so we don't want
to go after something
um
where the model is absolutely sure that
the proof size is infinite it's never
going to be absolutely sure um but if
that were the case the value would be
zero conversely if a model assigns the
is very sure or absolutely sure that
this proof is going to be
in the shortest bucket then the value is
one so this is a number between zero and
one depending on how short the proofs is
the proof is
so they say it prioritizes goals that
potentially lead to shorter proofs
during proof search
so that's how they guide their search
excellent
so these are the two objectives they
train with the one objective is to make
the model suggest
new the tactics to use and the other one
is to guide the proof search
by training the model to predict how
long a proof is going to be
so
yeah
the
next topic right here is how they how
they bootstrap the models so
in this expert iteration you always
train on your own outputs however there
needs to be like some sort of a some
sort of a starting point right
bootstrapping they say consistent step
required to train an initial model on
both proof step objective and the proof
size objective
um
they have two initial models in fact um
they have a
they have a data set which consists of
some of these proofs that have already
been proven
uh and they train a model with just a
proof step objective
which is called
theta0
so that's the initial model
then
they use
they use the initial model to sample
proofs for the statements in
this mathematics library
so they already use the model to
generate proofs
we denote the set of successful proof
searches created in processes s0 using
s0 we create a data set so the expert
iteration process essentially already
starts so they're going to concatenate
the original data set
sorry
the original data set
and a deduplicated set of proof steps
extracted from the proofs in s0
and a deduplicated set of proof size
tuples
extracted from the proof searches in s0
so now they're going to use whatever
they output as proofs in the last in the
last
in the last iteration
they're going to take that into the data
set they're going to create these proof
step
sentences i'm just going to call them
sentences because we're language
modeling right here
they're going to create these proof step
sentences like this one they're going to
create these proof size sentences like
this one and then they're going to train
a model again on that so they're going
to take
the
um they're going to take the theta 0 and
they're going to train it on that new
data
set
so that gives them theta 1 which is
trained on both the proof step and the
proof size objective and theta 1
is our first model in our expert
iteration
so now we are simply going to repeat
those things
each iteration k
consists in sampling proof searches
for statements
using the current model
filtering successful proof searches to
extract a new data set
and fine tuning
the theta 0 on it to obtain theta k plus
1. note that they don't they don't go
from theta 0 to theta 1 to theta 2 and
so on they always so they don't do that
they always go from theta 0 to theta 2.
then they use theta 2 to generate a data
set then they
fine tune theta 0 again to get to theta
three it'd be interesting to know why
they do it this way maybe if you
continue fine-tuning you're already sort
of locked into something so the
knowledge comes the knowledge the
unified knowledge comes from you can see
this right here the fact that they
the data sets they generate uh comes
from the unified set of all the
statements they've proven so far so all
the proofs they found so far they are
all go together into one big data set
for the next step so technically every
model can like re-learn the proofs
uh that the last model also knew because
it's they're they're in the same data
set
and you know potentially they also say
that they de-duplicate proofs which
means that for the same statements there
could be multiple proofs and they will
always take the shortest one so that
might be even disadvantage a
disadvantage if you were to tune from
like theta two
which would still
have learned a longer proof for a
particular statement and you'd have to
like forget that it's probably just
easier to scratch everything and start
with the shorter proof in your data set
and yeah that is it that's the expert
iteration process they
get a new model they use it to generate
new proofs
they add the proofs to the set of things
they know
and there is a set of things they don't
know right
because there can also be
bad proofs which serve as negative
examples which is also good
we can handle negative examples
and
then they get better and better
so now they are going to evaluate this
right now
you see that
they have various various ways of using
this model there's pass at eight there's
pass at one which essentially means like
how many tries
they give per expansion step like do we
sample do we try once do we try eight
times obviously the more you try the
longer your searches run but also the
the higher your chance of actually
finding something useful and these
things are mostly proportional to each
other so
it's just a matter of computational
effort you can see that
with expert iteration so the x-axis
right here is number of expert
iterations you can see they do nine
expert iterations um on these data sets
in general you see an upwards trend so
more and more statements are able to be
proven
uh by
the by the expert iterated system and
they have multiple data sets this mini
f2f is their final goal this is made up
of these various competition level
statements while the math lib um that is
more of these kind of formal proofs uh
from these from these formal
environments
and they do they do see that the overlap
isn't too great right here and you can
see that here as well
the scaling
only kind of sort of kicks in after a
while what also astounded me is that in
in both cases you have um solve rates
actually go down
intermittently
and i would be i would be very
interested you know why that is that
could be just like an effect of size or
something like this but
like why do solve rates go slightly
slightly down
or is it just noise i have no idea
you also see these are the cumulative
the cumulative pass rates
[Music]
and
so this is
this is the expert iteration
model and this is the sample only model
so in the blue model you run expert
iteration which means that you sample
data and then you retrain and then you
sample again and then you retrain
and in the orange model you only sample
so you only use the
you only use i believe the theta 0
which is the initial model you use that
to guide your search but you never
retrain on the things that you found
and interestingly obviously i guess uh
the expert iteration model way
outperforms the sample only model
however the sample only model uses less
compute because it doesn't have to do
the retraining so once you adjust for
that you can see it's this line right
here where at first the sample only
model is better
you know because the expert iteration
actually trains it wastes time and
training but as you go on if you give it
more and more compute
the
number of more statements that the
sampling only model solves it
underwhelms
with respect to what the expert
iteration solves and even on this data
set right here on this
more distant data set
there seems to be almost like a little
bit of a diminishing return
in the sample only method and at after a
while after a number of expert
iterations the expert iteration method
outshines the sample only method we
don't have an adjusted compute a curve
right here
but you can guess maybe that it might
look something
like this
possibly possibly just kind of like a
constant over the over the originally
orange curve
orange curve bad um
yeah
uh also let me know how you like this
this pre-annotation right here that i've
i've been doing now for two papers i
think
so i like pre-highlight them i i wonder
how that's how that's received if that
makes it more or less confusing
it just tells me a bit more where to
where to jump to
so we get some results right here uh the
number of statements proved in mathlete
train goes from
17390 at iteration 1 to
19476 at iteration 9 while the average
proof length of these statements goes
from 4.8 to 4.0
we hypothesize that this continuously
improving performance through expert
iteration stems from two effects so one
the model finding new original proofs
for the same statements which would then
be shorter
than the original proofs
and two the model closing marginally
harder statements at each iteration
which in turn provides more useful
training data for the next iteration uh
by iteration nine the model is trained
on more than ninety percent generated
data so the the original data set is
almost a is like a small minority of the
data that the model is trained on
again a another property that i haven't
even mentioned yet is that in proof
search you can verify a proof like you
know if a proof is correct which in most
domains isn't the case right so
retraining on your own output is
dangerous because
you don't exactly know how good it is
but here you can just verify that it's
good and then you know it's good data
right so it's a it's a bit of a special
environment but i think we can still
learn things from it
so what do they do they first train this
thing so
now i think the the setup is clear right
the expert iteration setup and they also
have made it clear that you know we can
reach harder and harder statements but
what we
maybe can't do is just jump to hard
statements we need
a curriculum we need
several various difficulties of
statements so that we can sort of uh
expand our knowledge again and again and
again
and they do first do that with synthetic
data so apparently apparently what you
can do
is you can do a you can make a synthetic
inequality statement generator which
gives you symbolic mathematical
inequalities and you can kind of control
how difficult they are so what they do
is they just
they just compose known inequality
theorems like holder inequality or
something like this they just compose
them and
how many times they compose them that
kind of measures how how difficult they
are so they have two parameters right
here that control how difficult they are
and
they they
generate a hundred statements of low
difficulty like these numbers pretty low
and they formalize a proof for each so
this is kind of their seed set
so two things you need so the you need
this seed
seed set of proofs
this is usually like some sort of a data
set um indeed in their case they combine
the this tactic data set that uh is
their seed data set
uh they combine this one with these 100
statements that they generate and they
prove themselves either themselves or
automatically so this would be this
would be the seed data set
and this thing right here that's the
curriculum
or just a collection of statements of
various
various difficulties the curriculum
doesn't need a proof right um this is
the key part right here the curriculum
simply gives the model an opportunity to
solve
continuously harder and harder problems
going from the seed right so going from
the seed you only need to be able to
solve the most easy problems in the
curriculum and then you can sort of rely
on the expert iteration on the self
bootstrapping to become more
to become better
results are here you can see that
for a given this this right here is it's
either the it's one of the n numbers uh
this right here so it the the color
measures the difficulty
uh zero is the easiest six is the most
most
hardest hardest difficulty
you can see that even for easy problems
expert iteration just manages to solve
much more
so much more problems and for the
hardest problems the
sample only method so if you just do
proof searching without expert iteration
it doesn't solve any of the harder
problems whereas the expert iteration
actually if you see like there's like a
tiny uptick at the bottom right here it
actually manages to solve some even of
the hardest category
so that gives a bit of credence uh yeah
they say here the the nd equals six
remains completely out of reach for of
simply scaling the number of attempts
per statements
which kind of means that you'd you'd
have to like invest a lot a lot of
compute if you just do proof searching
to match the too much
how good expert iteration is but compute
by compute is expert iteration is better
yeah so
they say well we're going to target this
mini f2f data set right this is our
final challenge
they say we curated and manually
formalized a set of math exercises to
target this data set
so this is
going to be their seeds and curricula
here
we hypothesized that if the difficulty
of the set of statements was made varied
enough expert iteration could
potentially leverage it to effectively
shift our model's distribution closer to
mini f to f's
and in turn improve their eventual
performance on it so they're going to
build they're going to build this
curriculum right here they're going to
collect
um
some
like 300 statements we manually
formalized it means just they bring it
into the syntax it doesn't mean they
also prove these statements right so
these will be these curriculum
statements um these come from like
books
math books that are used to prepare for
math exams
which are much closer to this data set
that they target
um
yeah so
this set of statements this is this is
this curriculum that i'm talking about
is the union um
the union
of the statements in my flip train this
they oh they interestingly they add
these inequalities that they've
generated uh to the set of statements
and also the these uh manually collected
things that they mentioned above and
with that
interestingly they do in fact uh get a
lot they get better on
they get better on this
mini f2f validation set
uh
so yeah you can see that
things go up which is a good sign
yeah again that you have like
different parameters this a parameter is
also i think a parameter of how many
times you sample per expansion or
something like this i don't know there
are many many parameters in these
searches but in general just from what
i've seen from this paper uh is you can
always trade off more compute like
trying more times
um expanding more times suggesting more
steps to do you can always trade that
for a bit more performance but the
general direction it doesn't matter in
in the general direction
um
yeah that's that's that obviously they
are better than
like the results are as you would expect
i think so
uh their models
are
generally better
than let's say the other models that
haven't been targeted at this data set
or the models that just do proof search
so they have a short discussion
of model size
they say we briefly experimented with
different model sizes and found that
model size scaling is not as
straightforward in the case of
as in the case of unsupervised learning
they found that bigger models
sorry they found that bigger models are
better in the sense that they
consistently exhibit a higher pass rate
if you just sample once however
uh despite that
it is often the case that for a fixed
amount of compute sampling more attempts
from a smaller model leads to better
final performance so these are these are
the sort of considerations that you have
to do if you have two independent
variables right you can trade them off
against one another um just for the
scale
with their big model running a full
expert iteration that's kind of one of
these
full expert iteration
uh full expert iteration do they mean
that all the nine steps or just one step
in the expert i'm going to guess all the
nine steps so the whole experiment to
get to their their their
model after nine expedition steps
required 2
a 100 days to compute
that is insane
running one full proof search uh when
properly parallelized requires on
average about 0.1 a 100 hours of compute
so that's like
it's like still a minute of an a100 um
crazy crazy
still so the the sizes here are
enormous right and still they are able
to solve what two of these olympiad
problems right um with
with with manual targetings with manual
data collection that is specifically
targeted at that data set and with 2000
a 100 days and
you know they don't solve all of them
they solve two
so
i believe this field is still in its
infancy um
i believe there's lots of stuff to do
right here there's probably approaches
that make these things a lot better
but i'm excited just because i think
that is an area where deep learning as
they say hasn't really pushed through
quite yet and i think there's a lot to
do to bring down the the requirements
here and the methodologies that they use
i like the way they combine the language
modeling
with the proof searching uh the expert
iteration might also be a nice lesson
for other fields like how can we combine
the neural models with some sort of
search procedures maybe or other
heuristics uh to generate ever better
training data that we can then feed back
to the models
all of this is highly interesting and i
yeah let me know what you think
and bye bye
[Music]
you